Well, I cannot believe you would bring that up, Connor. There's no way I'm discussing that. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 103, recorded on October 26, 2022. I'm your host, Connor, and today I interview the former co-host of the number one and most popular C++ podcast of all time, Jason Turner. All right, well, this is episode 101. Actually, is it going to be 101? Because I might record with Bryce before Friday. What is today?
Well, I cannot believe you would bring that up, Connor. There's no way I'm discussing that. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 103, recorded on October 26, 2022. I'm your host, Connor, and today I interview the former co-host of the number one and most popular C++ podcast of all time, Jason Turner. All right, well, this is episode 101. Actually, is it going to be 101? Because I might record with Bryce before Friday. What is today?|||好吧，Connor，真不敢相信你会提起这个。我绝不可能讨论这个。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 103 期，录制于 2022 年 10 月 26 日。我是主持人 Connor，今天我采访的是有史以来排名第一、最受欢迎的 C++ 播客的前联合主持人 Jason Turner。好的，嗯，这是第 101 期。事实上，会是第 101 期吗？因为我可能会在周五之前和 Bryce 一起录制。今天是几号？
October 26th. So this will either be episode 101 or it might be 103 or 104, depending on how the process of editing things works. But actually, it should be 101 because it's starting off the next 100 episodes with a new co-host. I'm not sure. So Jason, today with us, we have Jason Turner, who I'm pretty sure 95% of our listeners have to know who Jason is, obviously.
October 26th. So this will either be episode 101 or it might be 103 or 104, depending on how the process of editing things works. But actually, it should be 101 because it's starting off the next 100 episodes with a new co-host. I'm not sure. So Jason, today with us, we have Jason Turner, who I'm pretty sure 95% of our listeners have to know who Jason is, obviously.|||10 月 26 日。所以这要么是第 101 期，要么可能是第 103 期或第 104 期，这取决于剪辑过程是如何运作的。但实际上，它应该是第 101 期，因为它是带着一位新联合主持人开启接下来 100 期的第一期。我不确定。所以 Jason，今天在我们节目中，我们迎来了 Jason Turner，我敢肯定，我们 95% 的听众显然都知道 Jason 是谁。
I'll give the full introduction in a second, but co-host of the most popular and first C++ podcast in history, CppCast, which very sadly ended, I think it was about what, five months ago? May 12th, I think? That's about right. April, May, something like that. Yeah. And so the first question is, have you listened to any of the episodes of this podcast? I have not. Okay, so you don't know the lore. So the lore is that we started off on audio quality on a low note, which improved about five episodes in. That's what podcasts do. Yeah, and the enthusiasm was at a high.
I'll give the full introduction in a second, but co-host of the most popular and first C++ podcast in history, CppCast, which very sadly ended, I think it was about what, five months ago? May 12th, I think? That's about right. April, May, something like that. Yeah. And so the first question is, have you listened to any of the episodes of this podcast? I have not. Okay, so you don't know the lore. So the lore is that we started off on audio quality on a low note, which improved about five episodes in. That's what podcasts do. Yeah, and the enthusiasm was at a high.|||我等一下会做完整的介绍，他是 CppCast 的联合主持人，这是历史上最受欢迎、也是最早的 C++ 播客，该节目非常遗憾地结束了，我想大概是什么时候，五个月前？5 月 12 日，我想？差不多吧。四月、五月，差不多那样。是的。所以第一个问题是，你听过这个播客的任何一集吗？我没有。好的，所以你不知道这里的“传说”。这里的传说就是，我们开始时的音质处于较低的水平，大约在第五集左右有所改善。播客都是这样的。是的，而且当时的 Enthusiasm（热情）处于高潮。
And Bryce has basically gone downhill. You know, when we were interviewing Kate a few episodes ago, he was eating his dinner while we were interviewing her. You know, she couldn't stay focused. So I said, Bryce, you better be careful. You're on thin ice or I'm going to start auditioning new co-hosts. And that's what this is here. Oh, is that right? Kind of.
And Bryce has basically gone downhill. You know, when we were interviewing Kate a few episodes ago, he was eating his dinner while we were interviewing her. You know, she couldn't stay focused. So I said, Bryce, you better be careful. You're on thin ice or I'm going to start auditioning new co-hosts. And that's what this is here. Oh, is that right? Kind of.|||而 Bryce 基本上是一天不如一天了。你知道的，几集前我们采访 Kate 的时候，他在我们采访她的时候吃晚饭。你知道的，她无法集中注意力。所以我说，Bryce，你最好小心点。你如履薄冰，否则我要开始面试新的联合主持人了。这就是这里的由头。哦，是这样吗？算是吧。
Just kidding. Bryce doesn't even know that this is happening. Although he's in the midst of traveling right now. He was in Austin at a conference, I believe it was called O3DCon, which had to do with some open source engine. And he's going to Kona, which actually I don't. Is Kona next week? It's soon. I don't think it's happening right now. No, wait, it should be. It's always in February. That's what I thought. That's literally when Bryce brought that up an episode or two ago. He said, I'm going to Kona next. And I was like, wait, Kona's in February. And he said, no, no, Kona is happening shortly after his conference in Austin.
Just kidding. Bryce doesn't even know that this is happening. Although he's in the midst of traveling right now. He was in Austin at a conference, I believe it was called O3DCon, which had to do with some open source engine. And he's going to Kona, which actually I don't. Is Kona next week? It's soon. I don't think it's happening right now. No, wait, it should be. It's always in February. That's what I thought. That's literally when Bryce brought that up an episode or two ago. He said, I'm going to Kona next. And I was like, wait, Kona's in February. And he said, no, no, Kona is happening shortly after his conference in Austin.|||开玩笑的。Bryce 甚至不知道这件事正在发生。尽管他现在正在旅行途中。他在奥斯汀参加一个会议，我想它叫 O3DCon，这与某个开源引擎有关。他要去科纳（Kona），实际上我不知道。科纳是下周吗？快了。我觉得不是现在。不，等等，应该是。它总是在二月。我是这么想的。这正是 Bryce 在一两集前提起的时候。他说，我接下来要去科纳。我说，等等，科纳不是在二月吗？他说，不，不，科纳是在他在奥斯汀的会议后不久举行。
November 7th, it seems. Yeah. So then I think he's going to Kona and then he's going to Japan after that. Anyway, so he's in the midst of a lot of travel. And it's a perfect opportunity to bring Jason Turner on at the top of our first of the three-digit episodes. I guess technically episode 100 was that. Anyways. Did you start counting at zero or did you start counting at one? We were zero indexed, which I know it makes the nerds and I'm a fellow nerd as well happy. But it also irritates me that whenever we have to say like it's episode 100, we can't actually say it's our 100th
November 7th, it seems. Yeah. So then I think he's going to Kona and then he's going to Japan after that. Anyway, so he's in the midst of a lot of travel. And it's a perfect opportunity to bring Jason Turner on at the top of our first of the three-digit episodes. I guess technically episode 100 was that. Anyways. Did you start counting at zero or did you start counting at one? We were zero indexed, which I know it makes the nerds and I'm a fellow nerd as well happy. But it also irritates me that whenever we have to say like it's episode 100, we can't actually say it's our 100th|||似乎是 11 月 7 日。是的。所以我想他要去科纳，之后他要去日本。总之，他正处于大量的旅行之中。这是一个绝佳的机会，在我们三位数集数的首集开头邀请 Jason Turner 来做客。我想严格来说第 100 期就是那样的。不管怎样。你们是从零开始计数还是从一开始计数？我们是零索引的，我知道这会让书呆子们（我也是个书呆子）很高兴。但这也让我很恼火，每当我们需要说这是第 100 期时，我们实际上不能说这是我们的第 100
episode because it's always plus one to that, which is irritating. So episode 100, but you're 101st episode. Yeah. So this is technically episode 101 and our 102nd episode, which yes, it's very irritating. Zero indexing. That's why everyone should switch to APL because it's one index language. Oh, sorry. Anyway, so finish Jason's introduction for those that potentially aren't C++ developers, because although we brand ourselves as a C++ podcast, I think we're sort of polyglot. We talk about other languages at times. So
episode because it's always plus one to that, which is irritating. So episode 100, but you're 101st episode. Yeah. So this is technically episode 101 and our 102nd episode, which yes, it's very irritating. Zero indexing. That's why everyone should switch to APL because it's one index language. Oh, sorry. Anyway, so finish Jason's introduction for those that potentially aren't C++ developers, because although we brand ourselves as a C++ podcast, I think we're sort of polyglot. We talk about other languages at times. So|||集，因为它的编号总是要加一，这很烦人。所以是第 100 期，但却是你们的第 101 集。是的。所以这严格来说是第 101 期，也是我们的第 102 集，是的，这非常烦人。零索引。这就是为什么每个人都应该改用 APL，因为它是一种一索引的语言。哦，抱歉。无论如何，为那些可能不是 C++ 开发者的人完成 Jason 的介绍，因为尽管我们将自己定位为一个 C++ 播客，但我认为我们有点像是多语言的。我们有时会谈论其他语言。所以
we're going to do plugs for all of your stuff at the beginning and the end, because another thing that we do is this won't be dropped as one episode. We'll probably record for like an hour, 90 minutes, and then we slice them up into 30-minute episodes, which is another thing to be said. I tweeted out recently, and also you'll notice that we go on a bajillion tangents here. I tweeted out recently. I just realized I have listened to one of your episodes when you, uh, sliced up the one with, uh,
we're going to do plugs for all of your stuff at the beginning and the end, because another thing that we do is this won't be dropped as one episode. We'll probably record for like an hour, 90 minutes, and then we slice them up into 30-minute episodes, which is another thing to be said. I tweeted out recently, and also you'll notice that we go on a bajillion tangents here. I tweeted out recently. I just realized I have listened to one of your episodes when you, uh, sliced up the one with, uh,|||我们会在开头和结尾为你所有的东西做宣传，因为我们做的另一件事是，这不会作为单一的一集发布。我们可能会录制一个小时、90 分钟，然后把它们切成 30 分钟一集，这是另一件值得一提的事。我最近发了一条推特，你也会注意到我们在这里扯了无数个题外话。我最近发了一条推特。我刚刚意识到，我听过你的一集，当时你，呃，切剪了那一集，嘉宾是，呃，
with, uh, Sean parent. Ooh, we've done that a couple of times. So yeah, one of your earlier ones with him, I believe.
with, uh, Sean parent. Ooh, we've done that a couple of times. So yeah, one of your earlier ones with him, I believe.|||与，呃，Sean parent。噢，我们这么做好几次了。所以是的，我猜是你早期与他合作的其中一集。
Yeah, it might've been actually. Yeah. I think because I have listened to every single CPP cast episode, huge fan also to, I've, I've thanked, uh,
Yeah, it might've been actually. Yeah. I think because I have listened to every single CPP cast episode, huge fan also to, I've, I've thanked, uh,|||是的，实际上可能是的。是的。我想因为我听过每一个 CPP cast 的单集，也是超级粉丝，我曾，我曾感谢过，呃，
you and Rob multiple times on twitter but not technically i mean technically i did it on air but you weren't there um but anyways huge thank you to both um you and rob the amount of work that goes into cpp cast is probably a factor of five if not ten more than goes into this podcast which our listeners won't be surprised based on the quality but the fact that you, you're always pumping out roughly 60 minute podcasts, you're always having on guests, like organizing with guests, having multiple audio tracks, like the more audio tracks you have, the more work it is. Anyways, just like having now started one or two podcasts, I have a newfound appreciation
you and Rob multiple times on twitter but not technically i mean technically i did it on air but you weren't there um but anyways huge thank you to both um you and rob the amount of work that goes into cpp cast is probably a factor of five if not ten more than goes into this podcast which our listeners won't be surprised based on the quality but the fact that you, you're always pumping out roughly 60 minute podcasts, you're always having on guests, like organizing with guests, having multiple audio tracks, like the more audio tracks you have, the more work it is. Anyways, just like having now started one or two podcasts, I have a newfound appreciation|||你和 Rob 在推特上多次，但严格来说，我的意思是严格来说我在节目中表达过，但你不在，嗯，但无论如何，非常感谢你们两，呃，你和 Rob，投入到 CppCast 中的工作量大概是投入到这个播客的 5 倍甚至 10 倍，根据音质我们的听众对此不会感到惊讶，但事实上，你，你总是产出大约 60 分钟的播客，你总是邀请嘉宾，比如与嘉宾协调，拥有多个音轨，就像你拥有的音轨越多，工作量就越大。总之，就像现在刚开始制作一两个播客一样，我对
for the amount of work that goes into like a well-produced podcast that has constant guests and is not just reaching out like, cause that's the thing we bring guests on this podcast, but it's mostly guests that like people have heard of and that it's a quick email. Hey, would you like to come on? It's not reaching out into the community to find voices that, you know, haven't been heard before, which, you know, the first time I was on CPP cast, I was just someone who posted something on Reddit. And, um, I think, it's there's a lot to be what did I say on I misspelled
for the amount of work that goes into like a well-produced podcast that has constant guests and is not just reaching out like, cause that's the thing we bring guests on this podcast, but it's mostly guests that like people have heard of and that it's a quick email. Hey, would you like to come on? It's not reaching out into the community to find voices that, you know, haven't been heard before, which, you, the first time I was on CPP cast, I was just someone who posted something on Reddit. And, um, I think, it's there's a lot to be what did I say on I misspelled|||制作一个制作精良、有固定嘉宾且不仅仅是联系一下的播客所需要的工作量有了全新的认识，因为这就是我们在本播客中邀请嘉宾的情况，但大多数都是人们听说过的嘉宾，发个快邮件就行。嘿，你想来上节目吗？而不是深入社区去寻找那些，你知道的，以前没听过的声音，你知道的，我第一次上 CppCast 时，我只是一个在 Reddit 上发过东西的人。而且，呃，我想，有很多关于我在上面说了什么拼写错误的话
the word debt. But on Twitter, I quoted something about the deft of gratitude, which was supposed to be debt of gratitude, because I realized I began into Rust recently. And CppCast has produced more episodes. And you pointed this out of all the Rust podcasts combined, but also all the other C++ podcasts combined. We're not too far off from, well, what would we have done? 350 something? 300.
the word debt. But on Twitter, I quoted something about the deft of gratitude, which was supposed to be debt of gratitude, because I realized I began into Rust recently. And CppCast has produced more episodes. And you pointed this out of all the Rust podcasts combined, but also all the other C++ podcasts combined. We're not too far off from, well, what would we have done? 350 something? 300.|||debt（债务）这个词。但在推特上，我引用了一句关于 deft of gratitude（灵巧的感激）的话，本应该是 debt of gratitude（感恩之债），因为我意识到我最近开始接触 Rust 了。而 CppCast 制作了更多的单集。你指出了这一点：将所有的 Rust 播客加起来，以及将所有其他 C++ 播客加起来。我们距离，嗯，我们会做多少？350 多集？300。
Let's just go to... I'll leave a link in the description, but I have now on the ADSP website an other podcast tab, which keeps track of stats. Yeah, CppCast had 349 episodes in total. As you pointed out, more than all the other, more than all the Rust podcasts combined, also more than all the other C++ podcasts combined. But, you know, not too far off the mark from combining all of the Rust and C++ podcasts. Yeah, it's really, yeah, it's, you know, it's very, obviously, very obviously you know people you can't expect things to go forever but yeah it was a sad day because i know a ton of people including myself where you
Let's just go to... I'll leave a link in the description, but I have now on the ADSP website an other podcast tab, which keeps track of stats. Yeah, CppCast had 349 episodes in total. As you pointed out, more than all the other, more than all the Rust podcasts combined, also more than all the other C++ podcasts combined. But, you know, not too far off the mark from combining all of the Rust and C++ podcasts. Yeah, it's really, yeah, it's, you know, it's very, obviously, very obviously you know people you can't expect things to go forever but yeah it was a sad day because i know a ton of people including myself where you|||让我们直接去……我会在简介中留一个链接，但我现在在 ADSP 网站上有一个“其他播客”标签页，上面记录了统计数据。是的，CppCast 共有 349 集。正如你所指出的，比所有其他，比所有 Rust 播客加起来还要多，也比所有其他 C++ 播客加起来还要多。但是，你知道的，与将所有 Rust 和 C++ 播客结合起来的目标相去不远。是的，这真的，是的，这，你知道的，非常，很明显，非常明显，你知道人们不能期望事情永远持续下去，但是的，那是个悲伤的日子，因为我知道成吨的人，包括我自己，你
know friday morning there are certain podcasts that i listen to and you know i might not listen to immediately but like friday morning sometimes even thursday night if they dropped it's like one of the first things i do or you know i'll try and go for my run or go for a walk because it's like you get excited about you know being updated about the community that you partake in anyways so a huge huge thanks to both you and Rob for all the work you've done back to your introduction so not only were you the co-host of CppCast you have a very successful YouTube channel called C++ Weekly which I think has been going for like 300 plus weeks now. Yeah. I mean, I started it just a couple of months really after I started on CBPCast. So let's see, I just published episode 347. So it's been literally 347 weeks in a row.
know friday morning there are certain podcasts that i listen to and you know i might not listen to immediately but like friday morning sometimes even thursday night if they dropped it's like one of the first things i do or you know i'll try and go for my run or go for a walk because it's like you get excited about you know being updated about the community that you partake in anyways so a huge huge thanks to both you and Rob for all the work you've done back to your introduction so not only were you the co-host of CppCast you have a very successful YouTube channel called C++ Weekly which I think has been going for like 300 plus weeks now. Yeah. I mean, I started it just a couple of months really after I started on CBPCast. So let's see, I just published episode 347. So it's been literally 347 weeks in a row.|||你知道周五早上有些播客是我会听的，你知道我可能不会立即去听，但就像周五早上，有时甚至周四晚上如果它们发布了，这就成了我最先做的事情之一，或者你知道的，我会试着去跑步或散步，因为这会让你对了解你所参与的社区感到兴奋，无论如何，非常非常感谢你和 Rob 为之所做的一切。回到你的介绍，所以你不仅是 CppCast 的联合主持人，你还有一个非常成功的 YouTube 频道，叫做 C++ Weekly，我想它已经持续了 300 多周了。是的。我的意思是，我开始做它真的仅仅是在我开始做 CBPCast 的几个月后。所以让我们看看，我刚刚发布了第 347 集。所以确实是连续 347 周。
I have not missed a single week. There's once I published on Tuesday instead of Monday. Well, yeah, we're never going to forgive you for that. Yeah, that is also incredibly, incredibly impressive. And you're, I believe, I have this up. Yeah, 89.7 thousand subscribers. You're just around the corner from getting your first 100,000 plaque. That must be pretty exciting. I would love to get that.
I have not missed a single week. There's once I published on Tuesday instead of Monday. Well, yeah, we're never going to forgive you for that. Yeah, that is also incredibly, incredibly impressive. And you're, I believe, I have this up. Yeah, 89.7 thousand subscribers. You're just around the corner from getting your first 100,000 plaque. That must be pretty exciting. I would love to get that.|||我一期都没有错过。有一次我是在周二而不是周大发发布的。好吧，是的，我们永远不会原谅你这一点。是的，这也是极其、极其令人印象深刻的。而且你，我相信，我正打开这个。是的，8.97 万订阅者。你距离获得你的第一个 10 万订阅奖牌只有一步之遥了。那一定非常令人兴奋。我很想得到那个。
Yes, that is. I don't know. It's become a goal now. At first I was like yeah that'll never happen and now i'm like man ten thousand i can do this yep we should look up too let's quickly go to social blade which for those that are interested is the one of the statistics aggregator sites if we type in c plus weekly, it'll show us... Do you have a guess of how many millions of views?
Yes, that is. I don't know. It's become a goal now. At first I was like yeah that'll never happen and now i'm like man ten thousand i can do this yep we should look up too let's quickly go to social blade which for those that are interested is the one of the statistics aggregator sites if we type in c plus weekly, it'll show us... Do you have a guess of how many millions of views?|||是的，确实是。我不知道。现在这成了一个目标。起初我觉得，是的，这绝不会发生，现在我想，天哪，十万我可以做到，是的，我们也应该查一下，让我们快速访问 Social Blade，对于感兴趣的人来说，这是统计数据聚合网站之一，如果我们输入 c plus weekly，它会向我们展示……你猜有多少百万的播放量？
I know exactly how many if I go to my YouTube stats. YouTube just tells you that stuff. It's 6 million plus. That sounds about right. Which is, yes uh remarkable resource as well uh i've been a weekly watcher i don't actually know the number i started i want to say it was like in the 50s or 80s it was definitely double digits i think earlier on you sort of were doing um longer form live coding yeah live coding things like 30 minutes you know there were i think even
I know exactly how many if I go to my YouTube stats. YouTube just tells you that stuff. It's 6 million plus. That sounds about right. Which is, yes uh remarkable resource as well uh i've been a weekly watcher i don't actually know the number i started i want to say it was like in the 50s or 80s it was definitely double digits i think earlier on you sort of were doing um longer form live coding yeah live coding things like 30 minutes you know there were i think even|||如果我去我的 YouTube 统计数据，我很清楚有多少。YouTube 会告诉你这些东西。是 6 百万以上。听起来差不多。这是一个，是的，非常了不起的资源，呃，我一直是个每周的观众，我实际上不知道我开始看的具体数字，我想大概是在 50 多期或 80 多期的时候，绝对是两位数，我觉得早期的时候你做的是那种，呃，更长形式的实时编码，是的，像 30 分钟左右的实时编码，你知道的，我想甚至有
a few that were longer than that but then it switched to a 5 to 15 minute on average some go longer some are super short i'm just talking about all the different things i think i've even seen you on twitter say that you've are not sure like how much longer because you've done a video on basically every topic that could possibly be done uh is there an end in end in sight, a few months ago, I opened up a... I took my C++ Weekly GitHub repository, which has some code samples and stuff, but not very well maintained. And I created an issue tracker for every single episode idea that I had is now an issue.
a few that were longer than that but then it switched to a 5 to 15 minute on average some go longer some are super short i'm just talking about all the different things i think i've even seen you on twitter say that you've are not sure like how much longer because you've done a video on basically every topic that could possibly be done uh is there an end in end in sight, a few months ago, I opened up a... I took my C++ Weekly GitHub repository, which has some code samples and stuff, but not very well maintained. And I created an issue tracker for every single episode idea that I had is now an issue.|||比那还要长的，但后来它转变为平均 5 到 15 分钟，有些会更长，有些超级短，我只是在谈论所有不同的事情。我想我甚至在推特上看到你说过，你不知道还能坚持多久，因为你基本上对所有可能做的主题都做过视频了，呃，这有尽头吗？几个月前，我打开了一个……我拿出了我的 C++ Weekly GitHub 仓库，里面有一些代码示例之类的，但维护得不是很好。我创建了一个问题跟踪器（Issue Tracker），我所有的每一集节目构思现在都是一个 Issue。
And so anyone who cares can go on there and see all of the upcoming episode plans and post their own episode ideas as bug reports, basically. And I currently have 151 open episode plans on that list. Wow. Okay. So there's no insight then. Well, I mean, you know, I will stop.
And so anyone who cares can go on there and see all of the upcoming episode plans and post their own episode ideas as bug reports, basically. And I currently have 151 open episode plans on that list. Wow. Okay. So there's no insight then. Well, I mean, you know, I will stop.|||所以任何关心的人都可以在上面看到所有即将推出的节目计划，并将他们自己的节目想法作为 Bug 报告发布出来。我目前在该列表上有 151 个开放的节目计划。哇。好吧。所以看来是没有尽头了。嗯，我的意思是，你知道的，我会停下来的。
Well, what I've joked about in the past was that I will stop after I've covered C++. What did be the top content, C++ content creator. I don't think that's like an over-exaggeration. Like I'm not sure how you would rank other folks because there's tons of people that have websites and other amazing content, but just like on top of that, so we've mentioned the podcast, we've mentioned the YouTube channel. You also have a number of books.
Well, what I've joked about in the past was that I will stop after I've covered C++. What did be the top content, C++ content creator. I don't think that's like an over-exaggeration. Like I'm not sure how you would rank other folks because there's tons of people that have websites and other amazing content, but just like on top of that, so we've mentioned the podcast, we've mentioned the YouTube channel. You also have a number of books.|||嗯，我过去开玩笑说，我会在讲完 C++ 之后停下来。可以说是顶级的内容创作者，C++ 内容创作者。我不认为这是夸大其词。就像我不确定你会如何评价其他人，因为有成千上万的人拥有网站和其他了不起的内容，但除此之外，所以我们提到了播客，我们提到了 YouTube 频道。你还写了许多书。
I think, is it both puzzle books? And then there's also the best practices one. You also have a number of books. I think, is it both puzzle books? And then there's also the best practices one. C++ best practices and then seven puzzle books I've done now. Seven now, holy smokes. I haven't really advertised the last two because I kind of do a soft launch of them on LeanPub and then just see if anyone gives me bug reports and I give them for free to my top tier patrons. And so no one's given me any bug reports and I give them for free to my top tier patrons. And so no one's given me any bug reports. So it's kind of on my to do list, but it's been on the back burner to make those an
I think, is it both puzzle books? And then there's also the best practices one. You also have a number of books. I think, is it both puzzle books? And then there's also the best practices one. C++ best practices and then seven puzzle books I've done now. Seven now, holy smokes. I haven't really advertised the last two because I kind of do a soft launch of them on LeanPub and then just see if anyone gives me bug reports and I give them for free to my top tier patrons. And so no one's given me any bug reports and I give them for free to my top tier patrons. And so no one's given me any bug reports. So it's kind of on my to do list, but it's been on the back burner to make those an|||我想，是两本谜题书吗？然后还有一本最佳实践书。你还写了许多书。我想，是两本谜题书吗？然后还有一本最佳实践书。C++ 最佳实践，然后我现在完成了七本谜题书。现在有七本了，天哪。我没有真正宣传最后两本，因为我算是在 LeanPub 上对它们进行了软启动（soft launch），然后看看是否有人给我发 Bug 报告，我会把它们免费送给我的顶级赞助者。所以没有人给我 Bug 报告，我也把它们免费送给我的顶级赞助者。所以没有人给我 Bug 报告。所以这有点在我的待办事项清单上，但一直被搁置着，以便把它们变成
official release and then make them available on Amazon for print versions for people that want the print versions. Wow. So that's eight books in total. And on top of that, you are like an international. I mean, you weren't always an international keynote speaker, but you've spoken. I'm not sure how many talks like off the top of your head, do you know, over the last decade that you've given? Like, I imagine it's, I'm not nearly as prolific as some, I mean, you know, you take like Phil Nash, right? I don't even know how many talks he's given. I don't know Phil knows how many talks he's given. Um, let's see my YouTube playlist that i have all my public presentations in is as 28 so that does not include anything that i've done like privately for a recruiting event or whatever to company kind
official release and then make them available on Amazon for print versions for people that want the print versions. Wow. So that's eight books in total. And on top of that, you are like an international. I mean, you weren't always an international keynote speaker, but you've spoken. I'm not sure how many talks like off the top of your head, do you know, over the last decade that you've given? Like, I imagine it's, I'm not nearly as prolific as some, I mean, you take like Phil Nash, right? I don't even know how many talks he's given. I don't know Phil knows how many talks he's given. Um, let's see my YouTube playlist that i have all my public presentations in is as 28 so that does not include anything that i've done like privately for a recruiting event or whatever to company kind|||正式发布，然后将它们放到亚马逊上提供印刷版，供想要印刷版的人购买。哇。所以总共有八本书。最重要的是，你就像是一个国际级……我的意思是，你并非一直都是国际级的主旨演讲者，但你做过演讲。我不确定凭记忆你能说出多少次，你知道在过去十年里你做过多少次演讲吗？比如，我想这，我远没有某些人那么多产，我的意思是，拿 Phil Nash 来说吧？我甚至不知道他做过多少次演讲。我不知道 Phil 自己知不知道他做过多少次演讲。嗯，让我看看，我存放了所有公开演讲的 YouTube 播放列表是 28 个，所以这不包括我为招聘活动等私下为公司所做的事情
of thing yeah so that is and i've seen probably not all of them but definitely a large number of them i mean jason's a fantastic speaker there's a reason why you've gone from, you know, speaking at whatever level people start at to headlining conferences and stuff. Well, you said the first time we had you on CBPCast, you were just a guy who made a Reddit post. The first time I was on CBPCast, I was just a guy who had submitted a talk to C++.
of thing yeah so that is and i've seen probably not all of them but definitely a large number of them i mean jason's a fantastic speaker there's a reason why you've gone from, you know, speaking at whatever level people start at to headlining conferences and stuff. Well, you said the first time we had you on CBPCast, you were just a guy who made a Reddit post. The first time I was on CBPCast, I was just a guy who had submitted a talk to C++.|||之类的，是的，所以就是这样，而且我大概看过其中的大部分，虽然不是全部。我的意思是，Jason 是个极棒的演讲者，你从刚开始时在各种级别演讲，一步步走到成为各大会议的主旨演讲者等，这是有原因的。好吧，你曾说过我们第一次邀请你上 CppCast 时，你只是一个在 Reddit 上发帖的人。我第一次上 CppCast 时，我只是一个向 C++ 提交了演讲申请的人。
Now, I hadn't even spoken yet. Yeah, that's, I mean, that is, that should be very inspiring for listeners that currently haven't, you know, applied to speak at a conference or become engaged, even if it's just in their local meetup. Because I think a lot of the times that's, that's how it starts. You know, people, they try and find a local meetup, give a talk there, someone encourages them to speak at a conference. But there is a point in time for everyone, basically, where they don't have a, you know, outward facing public profile, if you will, or sort of social media presence in whatever community, whether that's C++, Python, Rust,
Now, I hadn't even spoken yet. Yeah, that's, I mean, that should be very inspiring for listeners that currently haven't, you know, applied to speak at a conference or become engaged, even if it's just in their local meetup. Because I think a lot of the times that's, that's how it starts. You, people, they try and find a local meetup, give a talk there, someone encourages them to speak at a conference. But there is a point in time for everyone, basically, where they don't have a, you know, outward facing public profile, if you will, or sort of social media presence in whatever community, whether that's C++, Python, Rust,|||当时我甚至还没做过演讲。是的，这，我的意思是，这对于那些目前还没有，你知道的，申请在会议上演讲或参与其中的听众来说，应该非常具有启发性，哪怕只是在他们当地的 Meetup 中。因为我认为很多时候，事情就是这样开始的。人们，他们试着找一个当地的 Meetup，在那里做个演讲，然后有人鼓励他们在会议上发言。但基本上对每个人来说，都有这样一个时间点，那时他们还没有一个，你知道的，面向公众的公众形象，如果你愿意这么说的话，或者在任何社区中缺乏某种社交媒体的存在感，无论是 C++、Python、Rust、
etc. And it starts with just, yeah, I guess applying. And yeah, that's, that's crazy to think. So that was episode, what was it? Two? Two, yeah. John Cobb was episode one. I was episode two. Because Rob had John on, and I guess he knew him because of the Microsoft MVP network. They're both MVPs. And then Rob sent out a call saying, anyone who's speaking at C++ Now is interested in becoming a guest on his brand new podcast.
etc. And it starts with just, yeah, I guess applying. And yeah, that's, that's crazy to think. So that was episode, what was it? Two? Two, yeah. John Cobb was episode one. I was episode two. Because Rob had John on, and I guess he knew him because of the Microsoft MVP network. They're both MVPs. And then Rob sent out a call saying, anyone who's speaking at C++ Now is interested in becoming a guest on his brand new podcast.|||等等。这一切都始于，是的，我猜是申请。是的，这，想起来真是太疯狂了。所以那是第几集？第二集？第二集，是的。John Cobb 是第一集。我是第二集。因为 Rob 请了 John，我猜他认识 John 是通过微软 MVP 网络。他们都是 MVP。然后 Rob 发出呼吁说，任何在 C++ Now 上演讲的人，如果有兴趣成为他全新播客的嘉宾。
And, well, okay. So this is like my secret to success, if you will. The listener is on the edge of their seat. Michael J. Fox movie, right? Secret of my success. I have no idea what you're talking about. Yeah, well, he like slept his way to the top. So that's not what I'm going with here. But I was underemployployed i had very little contract work available so i said all right i'm just not gonna say no to anything and and that came up so i saw the call for papers for c++ now and i'm like fine i'm gonna submit some talks i've never i've never talked before i'm gonna submit some talks they get accepted and then like so does anyone want to guest on CBP cast? And I said,
And, well, okay. So this is like my secret to success, if you will. The listener is on the edge of their seat. Michael J. Fox movie, right? Secret of my success. I have no idea what you're talking about. Yeah, well, he like slept his way to the top. So that's not what I'm going with here. But I was underemployployed i had very little contract work available so i said all right i'm just not gonna say no to anything and and that came up so i saw the call for papers for c++ now and i'm like fine i'm gonna submit some talks i've never i've never talked before i'm gonna submit some talks they get accepted and then like so does anyone want to guest on CBP cast? And I said,|||然后，好吧。所以这就像是我的成功秘诀，如果你愿意这么说的话。听众们正拭目以待。迈克尔·J·福克斯的电影，对吧？《成功秘诀》（The Secret of My Success）。我不知道你在说什么。是的，嗯，他靠着某种手段一路爬到了高层。这不是我要表达的。但我当时处于就业不足（underemployed）的状态，我能接到的合同工作非常少，所以我说，好吧，我对任何事情都不会说不，然后机会就来了，所以我看到了 C++ Now 的征文通知，心想，好吧，我要提交一些演讲，我从来没，我以前从来没做过演讲，我要提交一些演讲，它们被接受了，然后就像，有人想去 CppCast 做嘉宾吗？我说，
well, never been on a podcast before and I'm scared to death, but I said, I'm not going to turn down any opportunities. So I just, uh, to speak on CBP cast and just kind of snowballed from there, I guess.
well, never been on a podcast before and I'm scared to death, but I said, I'm not going to turn down any opportunities. So I just, uh, to speak on CBP cast and just kind of snowballed from there, I guess.|||嗯，以前从未上过播客，我吓得要死，但我说，我不会拒绝任何机会。所以我只是，呃，在 CppCast 上发表了讲话，从那以后事情就像滚雪球一样发展了，我想。
Yeah. And it's crazy to think because that's 2015, right? Like that, if this isn't, we're not even talking about like two decades ago, we're talking about like less than a decade ago was the first time you submitted to a conference and started co-hosting CPP cast till now. But in a way, my secret is being underemployed. Like every major change I've had in my career has come when I've been underemployed or unemployed. Yeah. I wonder if there's actually like, there's something there that when you are employed, you obviously that's 40, if not more hours of the week that are sucked up into obviously
Yeah, and it's crazy to think because that's 2015, right? Like that, if this isn't, we're not even talking about like two decades ago, we're talking about like less than a decade ago was the first time you submitted to a conference and started co-hosting CPP cast till now. But in a way, my secret is being underemployed. Like every major change I've had in my career has come when I've been underemployed or unemployed. Yeah. I wonder if there's actually like, there's something there that when you are employed, you obviously that's 40, if not more hours of the week that are sucked up into obviously|||是的，想起来真是疯狂，因为那是 2015 年，对吧？就像这样，如果这还不是，我们甚至不是在谈论二十年前，我们谈论的是不到十年前，那是你第一次向会议投稿并开始联合主持 CppCast，直到现在。但在某种程度上，我的秘诀就是处于就业不足状态。就像我职业生涯中的每一次重大变革都发生在我处于就业不足或失业状态时。是的。我想知道这其中是否真的有什么东西，当你被雇佣时，显而易见，一周中有 40 个甚至更多的小时被完全吸干了，显然是花在了
working for your company that prohibits a bunch of folks that might have, I don't want to say it's like an entrepreneurial spirit, but that's sort of like, just say yes to whatever opportunities it kind of is. Yeah. If there's something, I don't know if there's any countries that have uh you know more i don't know what the word is like liberal where education is free etc that like there's more of those kinds of things that happen because there's not this sort of big cloud over your head where you need to be employed to make money to fund your your living right like yeah yeah i mean you know let's be fair
working for your company that prohibits a bunch of folks that might have, I don't want to say it's like an entrepreneurial spirit, but that's sort of like, just say yes to whatever opportunities it kind of is. Yeah. If there's something, I don't know if there's any countries that have uh you know more i don't know what the word is like liberal where education is free etc that like there's more of those kinds of things that happen because there's not this sort of big cloud over your head where you need to be employed to make money to fund your your living right like yeah yeah i mean you know let's be fair|||为你的公司工作上，这阻碍了一群可能拥有——我不想说这就像是创业精神，但这有点像——对任何机会都说“好”的人。是的。如果有的话，我不知道是否有任何国家拥有，你知道的，更多，我不知道这个词是什么，比如更自由，教育是免费的等等，这种事情会发生得更多，因为没有那种沉重的阴影悬在你的头顶，迫使你必须为了赚钱维持生计而去工作，对吧，像，是的，是的，我的意思是，你知道的，公平地说
in the united states if i didn't have a job and I don't have health insurance and, you know, our social support program is relatively weak compared to a lot of the world. But, you know, I had learned at that point in my life to have very little debt and to have some savings. So when I was underemployed, I wasn't afraid that I wasn't going to be able to buy food. I just said, okay, now this is an opportunity. I'm going to take advantage of it. And it's still really weird to tell that story because I generally think of myself as a pretty lazy person.
in the united states if i didn't have a job and I don't have health insurance and, you know, our social support program is relatively weak compared to a lot of the world. But, you, I had learned at that point in my life to have very little debt and to have some savings. So when I was underemployed, I wasn't afraid that I wasn't going to be able to buy food. I just said, okay, now this is an opportunity. I'm going to take advantage of it. And it's still really weird to tell that story because I generally think of myself as a pretty lazy person.|||在美国，如果我没有工作，我也没有医疗保险，而且，你知道的，与世界上许多地方相比，我们的社会保障计划相对薄弱。但是，你在我那个人生阶段已经学会了拥有极少的债务并有一些积蓄。所以当我处于就业不足状态时，我不害怕自己买不起食物。我只是说，好吧，现在这是一个机会。我要利用它。讲述这个故事仍然觉得真的很奇怪，因为我通常认为自己是一个相当懒惰的人。
So I'm kind of surprised that when I had the available time, I did something with it. Yeah, I mean something with it. talking about that sort of, you know, he also was in that spot where he was working for, I think, Blizzard, or it was a, yeah, Blizzard at the time. And he basically wanted to sort of start building a public resume. And a great way to do that is by giving talks at conferences and stuff. And he said that he just basically started doing that and went from like zero to giving talks that were getting, you know, thousands and thousands of views online. And it's like, there's a lot of folks out there that probably could follow the same path. It's just, they're probably all thinking, oh, this is a huge mountain to climb, but one video a week. And then how many years later you've got 350
So I'm kind of surprised that when I had the available time, I did something with it. Yeah, I mean something with it. talking about that sort of, you know, he also was in that spot where he was working for, I think, Blizzard, or it was a, yeah, Blizzard at the time. And he basically wanted to sort of start building a public resume. And a great way to do that is by giving talks at conferences and stuff. And he said that he just basically started doing that and went from like zero to giving talks that were getting, you know, thousands and thousands of views online. And it's like, there's a lot of folks out there that probably could follow the same path. It's just, they're probably all thinking, oh, this is a huge mountain to climb, but one video a week. And then how many years later you've got 350|||所以我有点惊讶，当我拥有空闲时间时，我用它做了一些事情。是的，我的意思是做了一些事情。谈到那种，你知道的，他也曾处于那种境地，他当时在，我想是暴雪（Blizzard）工作，或者当时是一个，是的，当时在暴雪。他基本上是想开始建立一份公开的简历。而做到这一点的一个绝佳方法就是在会议等场合发表演讲。他说他基本上就是开始这样做，从零开始，到发表的演讲在线上获得，你知道的，成千上万的浏览量。这就好比，外面有很多人可能可以走同样的路线。只是，他们可能都在想，哦，这是一座需要攀登的巨大山峰，但每周一个视频。然后多少年后你拥有了 350
videos. You didn't go out probably thinking I'm going to make 350 videos over the next half decade plus. And it's going to be close to a hundred thousand subscribers. You probably just started out thinking I'm going to make a weekly YouTube channel and we'll see where this goes. And then like one of my favorite quotes is the most people overestimate what they can accomplish in a month and underestimate what they can accomplish in a year. The whole philosophy of like reading a few pages of a book a day. And then a couple months later, you know, you're done a book.
videos. You didn't go out probably thinking I'm going to make 350 videos over the next half decade plus. And it's going to be close to a hundred thousand subscribers. You probably just started out thinking I'm going to make a weekly YouTube channel and we'll see where this goes. And then like one of my favorite quotes is the most people overestimate what they can accomplish in a month and underestimate what they can accomplish in a year. The whole philosophy of like reading a few pages of a book a day. And then a couple months later, you know, you're done a book.|||个视频。你当时出门时可能并没有想过：“我要在接下来的五年多时间里制作 350 个视频。并且它将接近十万订阅者。”你可能刚开始时只是想着我要做一个每周更新的 YouTube 频道，然后看看这会发展到什么地步。然后就像我最喜欢的一句名言所说的那样：大多数人高估了他们在一个月内能完成的事情，却低估了他们在一年内能完成的事情。每天读几页书的这种整个哲学。然后几个月后，你知道的，你读完了一本书。
Yeah. I've just finished the book called Atomic Habits, which have you read that one? I have not read it, but I've listened to like two or three different podcasts, actually running podcasts that talk about the book of like forming habits that, you know, you don't say no to. And so you can consistently make progress at whether it's fitness or something else. Yeah. And it feels like, like his main thesis seems to be to make the habit goals, something that you're like, well, anyone can do that. Like you don't make a goal of going on a five mile walk.
Yeah. I've just finished the book called Atomic Habits, which have you read that one? I have not read it, but I've listened to like two or three different podcasts, actually running podcasts that talk about the book of like forming habits that, you know, you don't say no to. So you can consistently make progress at whether it's fitness or something else. Yeah. And feels like, like his main thesis seems to be to make the habit goals, something that you're like, well, anyone can do that. Like you don't make a goal of going on a five mile walk.|||是的。我刚读完一本书叫《原子习惯》（Atomic Habits），你读过那本吗？我没读过，但我听过两三个不同的播客，实际上是跑步播客，它们谈论过这本书，关于如何培养习惯，你知道的，你不会对它说不。这样你就能在健身或其他方面持续取得进步。是的。并且感觉，就像他的主要论点似乎是让习惯目标成为那种让你觉得“好吧，任何人都能做到”的事情。比如你不要把目标定为去散步五英里。
You make your your habit putting on your walking shoes. And now you're like, well, my walking shoes are on. I guess I may as well at least go on like a five minute walk. Or my goal is to read one page a day. And you're going to read more than one page. Almost certainly. But hitting that one page a day and you you're going to read more than one page almost certainly but hitting that one page is easy or i'm working on a book i'm going to write one sentence a day which is interesting because then he brings in quotes from other people who point out that like um other authors i forget who it was it was a it was a famous author anyhow that said, you know, like you need to stop writing while you're still in the groove.
You make your your habit putting on your walking shoes. And now you're like, well, my walking shoes are on. I guess I may as well at least go on like a five minute walk. Or my goal is to read one page a day. And you're going to read more than one page. Almost certainly. But hitting that one page a day and you you're going to read more than one page almost certainly but hitting that one page is easy or i'm working on a book i'm going to write one sentence a day which is interesting because then he brings in quotes from other people who point out that like um other authors i forget who it was it was a it was a famous author anyhow that said, you know, like you need to stop writing while you're still in the groove.|||你把你的习惯定为穿上你的散步鞋。现在你会想，好吧，我的散步鞋穿上了。我想我至少也可以去散步五分钟吧。或者我的目标是每天读一页。而你最终会读不止一页。几乎是肯定的。但达成每天那一页的目标很简单，或者我正在写一本书，我打算一天写一句话，这很有趣，因为随后他引用了其他人的话，指出像……其他作者，我忘是谁了，反正是一个著名作者，他说，你知道的，你需要在你还在状态（in the groove）的时候停止写作。
Like, don't try to force yourself to keep writing. Oh yeah. Yeah. Cause that's when you're going to hit like writer's block and all this. So if you make your goal to write like one sentence a day, then you're going to write as long as it flows. You're like,
Like, don't try to force yourself to keep writing. Oh yeah. Yeah. Cause that's when you're going to hit like writer's block and all this. So if you make your goal to write like one sentence a day, then you're going to write as long as it flows. You're like,|||比如，不要强迫自己继续写下去。哦，是的。是的。因为那时你将会遇到所谓的“作家窘境”（writer's block）诸如此类的情况。所以如果你把目标定为一天写一句话，那么只要文思泉涌，你就会一直写下去。你会觉得，
I met my goal of one sentence and then you're going to walk away comfortably before you hit the wall. That's. Yeah. That's really interesting yeah one of the one of the podcasts i listened to has uh this is a running podcast again because that's where most of this like self-help slash you know how to stay consistent uh they have a saying called one is greater than none and it's like if you ever feel like you don't want to get out the door whether you're walking or running or hiking whatever it is and you're sort of having a day where you feel like, ah, I don't really want to like their philosophy is like, always just go out and plan to just do like one kilometer or 10 minutes or something. And like almost always, like there are the rare
I met my goal of one sentence and then you're going to walk away comfortably before you hit the wall. That's. Yeah. That's really interesting yeah one of the one of the podcasts i listened to has uh this is a running podcast again because that's where most of this like self-help slash you know how to stay consistent uh they have a saying called one is greater than none and it's like if you ever feel like you don't want to get out the door whether you're walking or running or hiking whatever it is and you're sort of having a day where you feel like, ah, I don't really want to like their philosophy is like, always just go out and plan to just do like one kilometer or 10 minutes or something. And like almost always, like there are the rare|||我完成了写一句话的目标，然后你会在撞墙之前舒适地走开。就是这样。是的。这真的很有趣，是的，我听过的一个播客里有——这也是一个跑步播客，因为大部分这种自我帮助斜杠，你知道的，如何保持一致性，呃，他们有一句名言叫“一大于零”（one is greater than none），就像如果你有时觉得不想出门，无论是散步、跑步还是远足，无论是什么，你碰巧有一天觉得，啊，我真的不想去——他们的哲学就像是，总是直接出门，计划只做一公里或 10 分钟之类的事情。而且几乎总是，就像有少数
days where you get out, you do that 10 minutes and you're like, I'm going back home. But like almost always once you're out there, like you said, once you've started just doing it, you're like, ah, well I'm out here now, I I might as well just do like 5k or whatever it is or a 30 minute walk. And yeah, there's something to be said about just being consistent about whatever you're doing, whether that's podcasting or YouTubing or reading a book or. I never really thought about that specifically, but I don't run. I know I don't run nearly as far as you do, Connor, assuming you're still keeping up a pace that you were a few years ago. But there's only been a handful of times where I've been out on a run and I've actually come home sooner than I intended to. It's extremely rare.
days where you get out, you do that 10 minutes and you're like, I'm going back home. But like almost always once you're out there, like you said, once you've started just doing it, you're like, ah, well I'm out here now, I might as well just do like 5k or whatever it is or a 30 minute walk. And yeah, there's something to be said about just being consistent about whatever you're doing, whether that's podcasting or YouTubing or reading a book or. I never really thought about that specifically, but I don't run. I know I don't run nearly as far as you do, Connor, assuming you're still keeping up a pace that you were a few years ago. But there's only been a handful of times where I've been out on a run and I've actually come home sooner than I intended to. It's extremely rare.|||的日子你出门了，做了那 10 分钟，然后你会想：我要回家了。但几乎总是一旦你出门了，就像你说的，一旦你开始做了，你就会想：啊，既然我都已经出来了，我不妨就跑个 5 公里或者别的什么，或者散步 30 分钟。是的，关于无论你在做什么都要保持坚持这一点，确实有很多话可说，无论是做播客、做 YouTube、读书还是别的。我以前从没具体想过这一点，但我不跑步。我知道我跑得远不如你，Connor，假设你依然保持着几年前的那种节奏。但在我外出跑步的经历中，只有寥寥数次我实际上比预期更早地回到了家。这极其罕见。
It's usually longer. One time I'm out with the dog and I'm thinking, you know what? And actually, probably a lot of your listeners know Shiloh or I've met her from Twitter or something in person or met her at C++ now, but I'm out with Shiloh and I always like took the same route around the neighborhood. And my wife and I are both thinking like, if the dog were to like get lost, would she be able to find her way back home? And we're thinking, yeah, but she'd probably take the like three mile version, you know, all the way around the neighborhood to come back. And so I'm out running and, and it was just one of these days that we get here in Colorado where it's, it wasn't technically very's this breeze and you can just feel yourself mummifying. And I'm jogging and I'm like, man, it's hot, but I'm going to keep going. I had a goal. And the dog, she pulls back towards our house on a route that up to that point we i had never taken her on that route before and i'm like well the dog's clearly smarter than i am it is time to go home now that is a good uh
It's usually longer. One time I'm out with the dog and I'm thinking, you know what? And actually, probably a lot of your listeners know Shiloh or I've met her from Twitter or something in person or met her at C++ now, but I'm out with Shiloh and I always like took the same route around the neighborhood. And my wife and I are both thinking like, if the dog were to like get lost, would she be able to find her way back home? And we're thinking, yeah, but she'd probably take the like three mile version, you know, all the way around the neighborhood to come back. And so I'm out running and, and it was just one of these days that we get here in Colorado where it's, it wasn't technically very's this breeze and you can just feel yourself mummifying. And I'm jogging and I'm like, man, it's hot, but I'm going to keep going. I had a goal. And the dog, she pulls back towards our house on a route that up to that point we i had never taken her on that route before and i'm like well the dog's clearly smarter than i am it is time to go home now that is a good uh|||通常时间会更长。有一次我和狗一起出门，我在想，你知道吗？实际上，可能你的很多听众都知道 Shiloh，或者在推特上见过她，或者在 C++ Now 上见过她，但我正和 Shiloh 一起在外面，我总是喜欢沿着社区周围相同的路线走。我和我妻子都在想，如果这只狗迷路了，她能找到回家的路吗？我们觉得，会的，但她可能会走那种三英里的路线，你知道的，绕着整个社区一圈才回来。所以我在外面跑步，那正好是我们在科罗拉多会遇到的那种日子，技术上讲并没有什么微风，你简直能感觉到自己被做成了木乃伊。我慢跑着心想，天哪，好热，但我还是要继续。我有一个目标。而那只狗，它朝着我们房子的方向往回拽，走了一条直到那时我和我从没带她走过的路线，我想，嗯，这只狗显然比我聪明，现在是时候回家了。那真是一个好，呃
what do they call it uh canary you know if the dog wants to go home that probably it's uh it's above the temperature that is to be safe outside i, at this point, she's much older and slower than she was back then. So it's much more likely that she's like, no, I'm done. But then, yeah. Yeah, I'll put links in the show notes, the Atomic Habits. And also, too, so I feel like this is like a very long winded with some tangents introduction. So we talked about. Oh, wait, are we still in my introduction?
what do they call it uh canary you know if the dog wants to go home that probably it's uh it's above the temperature that is to be safe outside i, at this point, she's much older and slower than she was back then. So it's much more likely that she's like, no, I'm done. But then, yeah. Yeah, I'll put links in the show notes, the Atomic Habits. And also, too, so I feel like this is like a very long winded with some tangents introduction. So we talked about. Oh, wait, are we still in my introduction?|||他们叫它什么来着，呃，金丝雀（预警信号），你知道的，如果狗想回家，那可能说明气温已经超过了在户外安全的温度了，此时，她比当年老得多也慢得多了。所以她更有可能会觉得，不，我累了。但随后，是的。是的，我会在节目简介中放上链接，《原子习惯》。还有，所以我觉得这是一段非常冗长且带有题外话的介绍。所以我们谈论了。哦，等等，我们还在我的介绍阶段吗？
Yeah, we talked about the podcast, the YouTube channel, the books, all the talks. Conference talks. Which we'll put a link to all of that playlist. And also in a sec, we're going to talk about sort of what you've been up to for the last five months, including I know you were at CPP North and C++ on C before that. And I think you also had some training and there might be some conferences that I don't even know about. Is there anything else?
Yeah, we talked about the podcast, the YouTube channel, the books, all the talks. Conference talks. Which we'll put a link to all of that playlist. And also in a sec, we're going to talk about sort of what you've been up to for the last five months, including I know you were at CPP North and C++ on C before that. And I think you also had some training and there might be some conferences that I don't even know about. Is there anything else?|||是的，我们谈到了播客、YouTube 频道、书籍、所有的演讲。会议演讲。我们会把所有这些播放列表的链接都放上去。一会儿我们还要谈谈你过去五个月一直在忙些什么，包括我知道你参加了 CPP North，在此之前还有 C++ on C。我想你还做了一些培训，可能还有一些我甚至都不知道的会议。还有别的吗？
I mean, training, obviously, you do training if companies are individuals or I'm not sure if you do individual training. Individuals is weird because like economically and stuff, it's hard to make sense. I will throw out there, like if someone contacts me on Twitter and is like, hey, I have this open source project.
I mean, training, obviously, you do training if companies are individuals or I'm not sure if you do individual training. Individuals is weird because like economically and stuff, it's hard to make sense. I will throw out there, like if someone contacts me on Twitter and is like, hey, I have this open source project.|||我的意思是，培训，显然，如果公司需要的话你会做培训，如果是个人，或者我不确定你是否做个人培训。个人培训很奇怪，因为在经济等方面，这很难说得通。我会顺便提一下，比如如果有人在 Twitter 上联系我，说，嘿，我有这个开源项目。
I've got some questions about C++, whatever. I try to make time to talk to them. That's no guarantees at all. But I try to make time to talk to them. But yeah no guarantees at all. But I try to make time to talk to them. But yeah, one-on-one paid training, just like financially and schedule-wise, that's kind of weird. I don't tend to do that. But yeah, corporate training on-site specifically is what... And we're seeing that come back right now. It'm, it looks like I'm probably going to be busy through March at the moment. Oh, wow. Is it going to be, I assume most, most of it's going to be on the road or some of it? Yeah. That's what I'm saying. Yeah. Only one thing will be virtual. The rest of
I've got some questions about C++, whatever. I try to make time to talk to them. That's no guarantees at all. But I try to make time to talk to them. But yeah no guarantees at all. But I try to make time to talk to them. But yeah, one-on-one paid training, just like financially and schedule-wise, that's kind of weird. I don't tend to do that. But yeah, corporate training on-site specifically is what... And we're seeing that come back right now. It'm, it looks like I'm probably going to be busy through March at the moment. Oh, wow. Is it going to be, I assume most, most of it's going to be on the road or some of it? Yeah. That's what I'm saying. Yeah. Only one thing will be virtual. The rest of|||我对 C++ 有一些疑问，诸如此类的。我尽量抽出时间跟他们聊聊。这没有任何保证。但我尽量抽出时间跟他们聊聊。但确实没有任何保证。但我尽量抽出时间跟他们聊聊。但话说回来，一对一付费培训，从财务和日程安排上来说，有点奇怪。我一般不做那种。不过，专门的现场企业培训是……我们现在看到它正在回归。目前看来，我可能要一直忙到三月份。哦，哇。这会是，我猜大部分，大部分都会是出差在路上，还是只有一部分？对。这就是我要说的。对。只有一件事情是虚拟的。其余的
it will be on the road. Wow. Are you excited about that? I'm guessing. I think so. Uh, cause in 2019, I did six transatlantic round trips and like 25, 26 different training events. It was crazy. And I'm like, you know what? I really need to slow this down for 2020. and since you just mentioned like cbp north and cls plus on c like i found all of that incredibly stressful and overwhelming to be like thrown right back into the middle of that right now with uh all the people and covid concerns and all the things um but i i feel like i was starting to feel more like this it seems like it could be a normal groove again, but I'm definitely going to limit myself. I'm not going to do, you know,
it will be on the road. Wow. Are you excited about that? I'm guessing. I think so. Uh, cause in 2019, I did six transatlantic round trips and like 25, 26 different training events. It was crazy. And I'm like, you know what? I really need to slow this down for 2020. and since you just mentioned like cbp north and cls plus on c like i found all of that incredibly stressful and overwhelming to be like thrown right back into the middle of that right now with uh all the people and covid concerns and all the things um but i i feel like i was starting to feel more like this it seems like it could be a normal groove again, but I'm definitely going to limit myself. I'm not going to do, you know,|||都会在路上。哇。你对此感到兴奋吗？我猜是的。我想是的。呃，因为在 2019 年，我做了六次跨大西洋往返旅行，以及大约 25、26 场不同的培训活动。太疯狂了。当时我想，你知道吗？我真的需要在 2020 年放慢脚步。既然你刚才提到了像 CppNorth 和 C++ on C，我觉得所有这一切都令人难以置信地充满压力和压倒性，现在立刻又被扔回到那种环境中，带着，呃，所有的人群、新冠担忧以及种种事情，嗯，但我，我感觉我开始有这种感觉了，这似乎又可以成为一种正常的节奏了，但我肯定会克制自己。我不会去做，你知道的，
gone from the house two weeks a month in 2023. I'm not, that is not my goal. I might still do six Transatlantic round trips if people want to pay me to go to Europe six times. We'll have to see about that. Well, I mean, it is nice though though that you have the ability at least to choose the amount that you want to train right um obviously yeah 2021 2022 yeah um but i think i mean in-person conferences started coming back at some point this year and there are some that
gone from the house two weeks a month in 2023. I'm not, that is not my goal. I might still do six Transatlantic round trips if people want to pay me to go to Europe six times. We'll have to see about that. Well, I mean, it is nice though though that you have the ability at least to choose the amount that you want to train right um obviously yeah 2021 2022 yeah um but i think i mean in-person conferences started coming back at some point this year and there are some that|||在 2023 年一个月里离开家两周。我不会的，那不是我的目标。如果有人愿意付钱让我去欧洲六次，我可能还是会做六次跨大西洋往返。这还得看情况。嗯，不过话说回来，好歹你有能力选择你想要进行的培训量，这确实很好，对吧，嗯，显然，是的，2021 年，2022 年，是的，嗯，但我认为，我的意思是，线下会议在今年某个时候开始回归了，还有一些
are still virtual or hybrid but yeah it, it's, there's some amount of normalcy coming back. In-person training, I would say, I would argue is not really come back for me until like now, October, basically. I'm starting to see like people who had been wanting it for the last couple of years, but their company simply wouldn't allow it. Right. and then there's always like a about a three to nine month lag from the time that someone first contacts me to the time that i'm actually at their company right on the on the far in the extreme end i think it's been close to a year from the time of first contact i'll get like an email out of the blue from someone like yeah sorry this process is taking so long and i'm like the last email from you was like eight months ago I just I had put you in the like dead contacts folder we finally processed the email yeah
are still virtual or hybrid but yeah it, it's, there's some amount of normalcy coming back. In-person training, I would say, I would argue is not really come back for me until like now, October, basically. I'm starting to see like people who had been wanting it for the last couple of years, but their company simply wouldn't allow it. Right. and then there's always like a about a three to nine month lag from the time that someone first contacts me to the time that i'm actually at their company right on the on the far in the extreme end i think it's been close to a year from the time of first contact i'll get like an email out of the blue from someone like yeah sorry this process is taking so long and i'm like the last email from you was like eight months ago I just I had put you in the like dead contacts folder we finally processed the email yeah|||仍然是虚拟的或混合的，但是是的，它，它，有一定程度的正常状态正在回归。线下培训，我想说，我认为对我来说直到现在——基本上是 10 月份——才真正回归。我开始看到，在过去的几年里一直想要这个但他们的公司就是不允许的人。对。然后从有人第一次联系我到我真正去他们公司之间，总是存在大约 3 到 9 个月的滞后，在最极端的情况下，我认为从第一次联系开始已经接近一年了，我会突然收到某人的电子邮件，比如，是的，抱歉这个过程花了这么长时间，而我想，你发来的上一封电子邮件大约是八个月前，我刚才把你放进类似于无效联系人文件夹里了，我们终于处理完了那封邮件，是的
interesting so and I guess that makes sense actually because um there's a lot of meetups including the C++ Toronto meetup that I think would like to start doing in-person meetups again. But a lot of the companies that would sponsor spaces in the form of just saying, hey, come and borrow our level one or floor one or floor two meeting space that's easy for people to enter, and it's downtown. A lot of those companies still have policies of restricted external folks. And even for that matter, I'm curious as maybe how many of the companies you know, restricted external folks. Right. And even for that matter, I'm curious as maybe how many of the companies you're going to train at, it's going to be like the first time all of the employees are coming into the office or something because, you know, at any given day, 75% of them are working
interesting so and I guess that makes sense actually because um there's a lot of meetups including the C++ Toronto meetup that I think would like to start doing in-person meetups again. But a lot of the companies that would sponsor spaces in the form of just saying, hey, come and borrow our level one or floor one or floor two meeting space that's easy for people to enter, and it's downtown. A lot of those companies still have policies of restricted external folks. And even for that matter, I'm curious as maybe how many of the companies|||有趣，所以我想这其实说得通，因为，呃，有很多 Meetup，包括 C++ Toronto Meetup，我想它们都希望能再次开始举办线下的 Meetup。但是许多愿意提供场地赞助的公司，形式只是说，嘿，来借用我们的一楼或二楼的会议空间吧，那里方便人们进入，而且在市中心。其中许多公司仍然有限制外部人员进入的政策。不仅如此，我很好奇，也许有多少公司
from home sort of thing. So I'm sure that there's at least, you know, one of the companies that you go to that'll sort of be like that because even, you know, I work for NVIDIA, they have a Toronto office and I think they said something like, you know, it's like 15% occupancy of these. They've switched it all to like 80% flex desks where you can just say that you're coming in. You know, some people still have permanent desks. I think you have to be in the office for two or three days at least of the week to have one of those. Otherwise your desk got converted to sort of a, you know, rent, rent it for a day kind of thing. But the point being is that, you know, most people just work
you're going to train at, it's like the first time all of the employees are coming into the office or something because, you know, at any given day, 75% of them are working from home sort of thing. So I'm sure that there's at least, you know, one of the companies that you go to that'll sort of be like that because even, you know, I work for NVIDIA, they have a Toronto office and I think they said something like, you know, it's like 15% occupancy of these. They've switched it all to like 80% flex desks where you can just say that you're coming in. You know, some people still have permanent desks. I think you have to be in the office for two or three days at least of the week to have one of those. Otherwise your desk got converted to sort of a, you, rent, rent it for a day kind of thing. But the point being is that, you know, most people just work|||你将要去那里培训，这就像是所有员工第一次回到办公室一样，因为，你知道，在任何特定的一天里，他们当中有 75% 的人在家里办公。所以我确信，你知道，你去的公司中至少有一家会是那种情况，因为甚至，你知道，我在英伟达（NVIDIA）工作，他们在多伦多有一个办公室，我想他们说过类似的话，你知道的，这里的占用率大概是 15%。他们已经把所有的都换成了大约 80% 的灵活办公桌（flex desks），你可以直接说你要来上班。你知道，有些人仍然有固定的办公桌。我想你必须一周在办公室待两到三天才能拥有一个那样的办公桌。否则你的办公桌就会变成某种，你，租一天的形式。但重点是，你知道的，大多数人只是在
from home unless if they have a reason to be in the office. Yeah, the company that hosts my meetup, actually, what have we been meeting in person again now for five, five months, I want to. And there's another thing to mention that you're co are you co organizer, organizer, I am the organizer of my meetup technically i am the one technically in charge of it but um it's one of those things it would not happen nearly as smoothly as it does if i didn't have a whole team of people that just kind of make things happen right uh it's particularly the people at the company who host this they're regulars you know they're the ones always there. And then I've got
from home unless if they have a reason to be in the office. Yeah, the company that hosts my meetup, actually, what have we been meeting in person again now for five, five months, I want to. And there's another thing to mention that you're co are you co organizer, organizer, I am the organizer of my meetup technically i am the one technically in charge of it but um it's one of those things it would not happen nearly as smoothly as it does if i didn't have a whole team of people that just kind of make things happen right uh it's particularly the people at the company who host this they're regulars you know they're the ones always there. And then I've got|||家里工作，除非他们有理由去办公室。是的，主办我的 Meetup 的那家公司，实际上，我们现在恢复线下聚会多久了？五个月了，我想。还有一件事要提，你是共同，你是共同组织者，组织者，我是我的 Meetup 的组织者，从技术上讲，我是真正负责它的人，但是，嗯，这是那种如果没有一整群人来推动事情发生，事情就不会进展得这么顺利的事情，呃，特别是主办这个活动的公司的那些人，他们是常客，你知道他们是总在那里的人。然后我有
a company that provides our food. So we always have like good food to eat. It's not like, you know, $10 worth of pizza kind of thing. But you know, we've had in the past, like pre COVID, we would have like, Japanese spread like buffet brought out like this is amazing but anyhow uh yeah at my meetup i think we've been meeting back there for like five months now and i just did a training at the company that hosts the meetup and a considerable number of the people who are were employees local employees at the company all coming in like shaking hands like oh i haven't seen you in a year good to see you yeah yeah they have a reason to come into the office now yeah and i tell them all you could come to the meetup and see each other more often all right so yeah organizer of uh i think it's it's the official title is the
a company that provides our food. So we always have like good food to eat. It's not like, you know, $10 worth of pizza kind of thing. But you know, we've had in the past, like pre COVID, we would have like, Japanese spread like buffet brought out like this is amazing but anyhow uh yeah at my meetup i think we've been meeting back there for like five months now and i just did a training at the company that hosts the meetup and a considerable number of the people who are were employees local employees at the company all coming in like shaking hands like oh i haven't seen you in a year good to see you yeah yeah they have a reason to come into the office now yeah and i tell them all you could come to the meetup and see each other more often all right so yeah organizer of uh i think it's it's the official title is the|||一家提供我们食物的公司。所以我们总是有好吃的。这不像是，你知道的，价值 10 美元的披萨那种东西。但你知道，过去我们曾有过，比如在疫情前，我们会像日式自助餐那样摆出来，这太棒了，但不管怎样，呃，是的，在我的 Meetup，我想我们在那里恢复聚会大约有五个月了，我刚刚在主办 Meetup 的那家公司做了一次培训，相当多的员工——当地公司的员工——都走了进来，握手致意，就像“哦，我一年没见你了，很高兴见到你”，是的，是的，他们现在有理由来办公室了，是的，我告诉他们所有人，你们可以来参加 Meetup，更常见地见到彼此。好吧，所以，是的，……的组织者，我想它的，正式头衔是
north denver c++ meetup is that correct i did actually just change it to the Denver C++ Meetup. Oh, now it's all of Denver, not just North Denver. All right. Well, you know, it's like a historical reason. The original C++ Meetup in the area met way south. And then my host at the time, Scott Fredrickson, he was the host of that meetup. He said, you know what? It just doesn't make sense for me to keep doing this. I'm not using C++ regularly anymore. Not that many
north denver c++ meetup is that correct i did actually just change it to the Denver C++ Meetup. Oh, now it's all of Denver, not just North Denver. All right. Well, you know, it's like a historical reason. The original C++ Meetup in the area met way south. And then my host at the time, Scott Fredrickson, he was the host of that meetup. He said, you know what? It just doesn't make sense for me to keep doing this. I'm not using C++ regularly anymore. Not that many|||北丹佛 C++ Meetup，对吗？我实际上刚刚把它改成了丹佛 C++ Meetup。哦，现在是整个丹佛，而不仅仅是北丹佛。好吧。嗯，你知道的，这就像是一个历史原因。该地区的最初的 C++ Meetup 聚会在很南方。然后我当时的东道主 Scott Fredrickson，他是那个 Meetup 的主持人。他说，你知道吗？我继续做这个已经没有意义了。我不再经常使用 C++ 了。没有那么多
people come who even use C++. So he shut down the meetup and asked me if I want to take it over. And I'm like, I am not driving, you know, in traffic, like an hour and 15 minute drive. So I would leave my house two hours before the meetup and go to Starbucks so that it was only a 30 minute drive. Like, cause you know, it's straight through the heart of downtown Denver work traffic. So I said, no, I'm not going to do that. We're just going to let the meetup die. And then it was like six months or a year later or something. I'm like, all right, fine. I'm going to try restarting this meetup. And I wanted to make it clear that we weren't meeting down there anymore. We're meeting up here where I live. So I said the North Denver Metro C++ meetup. And since then,
甚至还有使用 C++ 的人来。所以他关闭了线下聚会，并问我想不想接手。我说，我可不想在交通高峰期开车，单程要一个小时十五分钟。所以我会在聚会开始前两个小时离开家，先去星巴克，这样开过去就只要三十分钟了。因为你知道，那是穿过丹佛市中心交通最繁忙的路段。所以我说，不，我才不这么干。我们干脆让这个聚会解散算了。然后大约过了六个月还是一年什么的，我想，好吧，行。我打算试着重新举办这个聚会。我想明确表示我们不再去那边聚会了。我们要在我住的地方这边聚会。所以我把名字改成了“北丹佛大都会 C++ 聚会”。从那以后，
hundreds of people have told me that that is way too long of a name. I've always wondered if there was like an East, West and South ones that just are not active. But formerly, I just wanted to make it clear it wasn't still the one down in south denver right so now now formerly the formerly the north denver c++ meetup now the denver c++ meetup which speaking of how you said that you know some folks want um help with like github repo reviews is there was back you know the i would say i didn't go to every single virtual C plus plus meetup, but at the beginning of the pandemic, I was probably at virtual meetups,
几百个人告诉我，这个名字实在是太长了。我一直很好奇是不是还有东部、西部和南部的聚会只是不活跃而已。不过以前，我只是想明确说明它已经不是原来那个在丹佛南部的聚会了，对吧？所以现在，以前的“北丹佛 C++ 聚会”现在改成了“丹佛 C++ 聚会”。说到你刚才说的，你知道有些人想要像 GitHub 仓库审查这样的帮助，以前，你知道，我会说我并没有参加每一个虚拟的 C++ 聚会，但在疫情初期，我大概参加了虚拟聚会，
like three nights of the week, not all C plus plus, but like, I went to the San Diego one. I went to the Denver one. I went to a bunch of European ones. Uh, the C plus plus Toronto one had them. And of the ones I went to, uh, the Denver one was my favorite by far. And in one of them, you actually did like suggestions of like, do people have repos they want me to look at? So you could have gotten free code reviews if you had been a registered member of that meetup group. I don't think the group meets virtually anymore, but you know, I would still stream as often
一周大概有三个晚上，不全都是 C++ 的，比如我去过圣迭戈的，去过丹佛的，还去过一堆欧洲的。呃，多伦多 C++ 聚会也有。在我去过的这些里面，呃，丹佛的那场绝对是我最喜欢的。其中有一次，你真的提出了这样的建议，比如：“大家有没有希望我来看看的代码仓库？”所以如果你是那个聚会小组的注册成员，你本可以获得免费的代码审查。我觉得这个小组现在大概不在网上举行虚拟聚会了，不过你知道，只要我们技术上能够对聚会进行直播，
as we are technically capable of streaming the meetup. Okay, well, there you go. So if you are interested in that, they have a great group of folks and rotating presenters that are, you know, have spoken at conferences that are, yeah, a great set of speakers. Anything else to close out? This is like the first snippet of this conversation
我还是会尽可能经常地进行直播。好吧，那就这样。所以如果你对此感兴趣，他们有一群很棒的成员和轮流上台的演讲者，他们都是曾在各大会议上发言的人，呃，是一群非常出色的演讲者。还有什么要总结的吗？这次对话的第一个片段
is just introducing Jason Turner. I think we've taken some tangents. No, I think we've covered it. You know, I'm on an airplane, and the person beside me is like, so why are you coming to my small town? Because a lot of C++ development happens in rural America
其实只是在介绍杰森·特纳（Jason Turner）。我觉得我们扯得有点远了。不，我觉得我们已经聊得差不多了。你知道，我在飞机上，坐在我旁边的人问：“你为什么来我们这个小镇？”因为很多 C++ 开发都发生在农村地区的美国，
where no one would expect it to be, right? Like, I've been to Bellingham, Washington. I've been to Peoria, Illinoishington i've been to peoria illinois like for c++ companies right and people are always like so what brings you to this small town on this puddle jumper of an airplane right i'm like oh well you know i do some training and they'll always guess what company i'm there for because there's always one big company that's in the thing whatever or whatever and and you know when people ask me what i do i'm just like i don't know like i do things and so i i've just kind of degraded to often just telling people i'm a youtuber because i feel like that's the easiest
这是大家意想不到的，对吧？比如，我去过华盛顿州的贝灵汉。我去过伊利诺伊州的皮奥里亚——我是说去那些做 C++ 的公司，对吧？人们总是问：“是什么风把你吹到这架支线飞机上的小镇来的？”我说：“哦，你知道的，我做一些培训。”然后他们总是能猜出我是为哪家公司来的，因为那地方总有一家大公司，诸如此类的。而且你知道，当别人问我是做什么的时，我通常会说：“我不知道，我就是做点各种事情。”所以我现在基本上已经沦落到直接告诉别人我是一名视频创作者（YouTuber），因为我觉得那是最好回答的
answer that's true i mean you wear you wear many hats um i think yeah youtuber i'm not sure if it's in your twitter bio oh, we should mention that. I don't think this ever gets mentioned. And it's a shame. The one thing that it's a shame that Bryce isn't here is that if Bryce was here, you could dunk on him. You probably wouldn't. But I would dunk for you on him over the fact that you've got like 8,000 more Twitter followers. Because it's something Bryce loves to bring up of how many Twitter followers he has.
答案。确实是这样，我的意思是你有许多不同的身份。我想，对，YouTuber，我不确定它是不是写在你的 Twitter 简介里。哦，我们应该提一下这个。我觉得这事从来都没人提过，真是太遗憾了。唯一遗憾的是布莱斯（Bryse）不在这里，如果他在的话，你就可以顺便嘲讽他一番。你可能不会，但我会替你在他面前嘲讽他，因为你的 Twitter 粉丝比他多大约 8,000 个。因为布莱斯非常喜欢拿他有多少 Twitter 粉丝这件事出来说事。
And he's got more followers than JF. And I think you've got 20. I have 22.1. Yeah, right now. Yeah. And I think Bryce last time I checked was 12 or 13,000. And so more like 10,000 than him as long as we're going there. Oh, 13,000. No, only 9,000. So you heard it here first, folks, is Jason Turner has more Twitter followers than Bryce. I think a few of our guests, actually. I think Chandler, Chandler Cruz has been on the podcast. He's definitely got more than Bryce. I don't know who the top C++ Twitter person is. Not that it matters, but I mean, you've got to be in the top five, at least. I don't know many folks that have 20,000 plus. I believe I am in the top five. But like i said it's rare that i look at this jens
而且他的粉丝比 JF 还多。我想你有 2 万……我有 22,100 个。是的，就现在。没错。我想布莱斯我上次看的时候是 1.2 万或者 1.3 万。所以既然我们聊到这儿了，你的粉丝比他多差不多 10,000 个。哦，1.3 万？不对，只有 9,000。所以各位，你们在这里第一次听到，杰森·特纳的 Twitter 粉丝比布莱斯多。我觉得我们的一些嘉宾也是这样，实际上。我想钱德勒·卡尔（Chandler Carr）上过这个播客，他的粉丝绝对比布莱斯多。我不知道谁是 C++ 圈 Twitter 粉丝最多的人。倒不是说这有多重要，但我的意思是，你至少应该在前五名之列。我不认识多少粉丝超过两万的人。我相信我是在前五名里的。但就像我说的，我很少去看这个。延斯（Jens），
um has been way more consistent way longer than the rest of us okay and it's actually jens veller has i just double checked 28 000 oh there you go that's and might be number one for people who have a ton of followers but aren't very active on twitter herb has 24 000 followers okay yeah that makes you number three. And for those that don't know, Jens is the organizer of the Meeting C++ conference, which I believe should just be coming up. I mean, if this gets released as episode 101, it should be in the next couple weeks in November, I think. Yeah. And their conference is hybrid. I know it was hybrid last year. I'm not sure if it's still hybrid this year.
呃，比我们其余所有人坚持得都更久、更稳定。事实上，延斯·维勒（Jens Weller），我刚查了一下，有 28,000 个粉丝。哦，原来如此。对于那些粉丝众多但在 Twitter 上不是很活跃的人来说，他可能是第一名。赫布（Herb）有 24,000 个粉丝。好吧，是的，这让你排在第三位。对于那些还不知道的人来说，延斯是 Meeting C++ 会议的组织者，我想这个会议应该马上就要举行了。我的意思是，如果这期节目作为第 101 集发布，那它应该就在十一月接下来的几周内，我想是的。是的。而且他们的会议是线上线下结合的（hybrid）。我知道去年是线上线下结合的。我不确定今年是不是还是这样。
I think it's planning to be hybrid this year too. No, I just made me pull it up because I'm curious. It is hybrid. Yeah. And it's November 17th through the 19th in Berlin for those who don't know that. Yeah. It's a great conference. I was there in person in 2019 and then virtually in 2020.
我想今年也计划办成线上线下结合的。不，这让我忍不住去查了一下，因为我很好奇。确实是线上线下结合的。是的。而且就在 11 月 17 日到 19 日在柏林举行，对于那些不知道的人来说。是的。这是一个很棒的会议。我在 2019 年去现场参加过，然后在 2020 年通过虚拟方式参加了。
And yeah, fantastic conference, fantastic speakers. It's a different vibe than a few conferences because they provide meals, I think, on all of the days or most of the days. That might be right. And so you kind of everyone's co-located or located in the same spot for, you know, all of the, the three days, I think it lasts for, um, anyways, speaking of conferences, we can switch to kind of episode two tune in next week for part two of this three-part interview with Jason Turner. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，非常棒的会议，非常棒的演讲者。它和其他一些会议有点不同的氛围，因为我想他们所有天数或大部分天数都提供餐饮。这可能是真的。所以基本上每个人都在同一个地方，你知道的，在这持续的三天里都在一起。不管怎样，说到会议，我们可以切入第二集。请收听下周三部分采访杰森·特纳的第二部分。感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。